Matthew is with us in Minneapolis hi
Matthew how are you good yourself better
than I deserve what's up i - quick
question
um so my wife and i are are willing to
pay off debt but she is thinking that
the program is sort of micromanaging or
money not me but and that's where I'm
having issues I'm trying to explain to
her like the steps of the baby steps and
why it's important to say for sinking
funds etc but I just don't know really
what to do
Perseids get like a separate checking
account and then to have our bills come
from there why would you get a separate
checking account because she doesn't
agree
no no just a separate checking account
like for our bills why not why can you
not come into agreement with what you're
gonna do with your money we just have
like this different
I guess beliefs I guess I'm trying to
say how to clean it yeah she doesn't
like going down to the zero based budget
which I do okay
but her plan doesn't work right so this
is not let me just tell you very very
few couples become wealthy when they're
not on the same page right almost never
happens and so it is essential that the
two of you continue to work work work on
your relationship and find some common
ground and develop some kind of a plan
that the two of you both can work and
write you know her obstinance to doing a
plan try it just try it you know I have
a feeling that you're tightening the
screws down so tight on this budget that
she can't breathe right and that and
that's the thing where I need to be a
little bit more open-minded I think -
yeah I think you probably need to
lighten up on write some of your legal
and some of your I mean you're just
enthused and fired up and in in that
enthusiasm you your your loot your
winning the battles but you're losing
the war the war is getting your wife and
you on the same page
I would rather you give up some of the
minor issues here so that you guys can
get on the same page so loosen up some
of these categories give her some more
room
let her vote count more so that she
feels her vote counting and let's get on
the same page here because that that's
what's important no I do not want to
prepare for your divorce by you
separating your money no thank you
I want you learning to work together
because I want your marriage to get
better that it is now